Hi, I’m Thomas Frank and I wanna welcome you to
a series that’s a little bit different than anything you’ve
seen here on Crash Course before.
While every other series up to this point has helped
you explore and learn about actual academic subjects,
like World History, Computer Science, and
Literature, here we’ll be learning how to learn.
This is an important ability to have and to
hone;
as our economy becomes more and more dominated
by information,
the people who can retain that information,
learn new skills quickly,
and combine what they know in new and innovative
ways are gonna be the ones who succeed.
Plus, when you know how to study efficiently
for a test, you’ve got more time for Mario Kart.
So, I should probably introduce myself.
My name is Thomas Frank and I’m the founder
of College Info Geek.com
I’m also the author of a book called 10
Steps to Earning Awesome Grades,
and I’m the creator of a YouTube channel
that’s all about becoming a more effective
student.
I also have a podcast where I get together
with my best friend Martin and we discuss
many of these topics in even more depth.
For the past 7 years, I’ve spent a huge amount of time writing and researching all about how we as humans can improve our ability to learn and become more productive.
I’ve interviewed college professors, authors,
sleep doctors, neuroscientists, and other experts.
And along the way I’ve picked up a few tips
that go beyond the basics that you might have
already been taught.
So, over the course of the next 10 episodes
I’ll be sharing what I’ve learned.
Among other things, we’ll be digging into how to
effectively take notes, tackle reading assignments,
write papers, and – of course – study for tests.
We’ll explore how your memory works, and look at
study strategies that take advantage of its limitations,
rather than working against them.
We’ll also cover productivity skills like
planning, beating procrastination, and improving
your concentration –
skills that will serve you both in your life
as a student and wherever you decide to go
afterwards.
And that’s really the thing with study skills.
As I’ve discovered since graduating college
with an Information Systems degree a few years
ago, and as you’ll inevitably discover as well,
the skills that enable you to ace your tests and
keep all your assignments organized will transfer to
your career and help you succeed there as well.
Welcome to Crash Course Study Skills.
I’ll see you next week.